has this been licked by someone gosh I
don't know you know who knew there were
so many different like this one it's so
gross hi my name's Leah hey my name is
Andrew Hey I'm destiny hi my name is Liz
and today we're trying some barbecue
sauce I'm excited yeah it depends on the
chicken my barbecue sauce preferences
depend on the chicken I am a southern
girl I need all the barbecue I'm a
Southern California boy no I love
barbecue sauce there's so many different
kinds it's like the tangy time there's a
sweet kind there's like a smoked kind I
think I love it but I feel like I'd I
don't know it as much as I thought I did
okay let's go let's try to bring it
there Nona so what's this oh oh oh no I
can tell oh this is Wendy's I can tell
I'm it's got like a head and shoulders
viscosity hmm wow this little kick a dip
it dip in it all right here we go
lord be a fan the chicken really brings
out the UH the peppercorn undertones
it's sweet it's really sweet yeah really
really sweet they're hiding something
with that sugar oh yeah I don't know I
mean it's just it's good I like it that
it doesn't have like one single flavor I
like that it's not super sweet has a lot
of depth to it I think it's weird to
have a barbecue sauce on Friday it's a
little different yeah yeah yeah I'm
usually like off the grill and gonna
like slathered in barbecue I'm even
trying to think like when you make wings
wings you bake it in the barbecue sauce
I say okay I'm learning yeah you're
learning that I'm a good almost like a
dipping and a pouring kind of guy you're
Southern California baby I can't expect
much more but like the north part of
Southern California
[Music]
what is this call what's the proper term
I really don't like the way that this
movie like
[Music]
what's the name of it no I'm trying to
think of a name I've never eaten
barbecue sounds like this before it may
be when you apply these that'll pop
you're supposed to like that's what
Paula Deen would do and it's like a
barbecue sauce it's like the standard
barbecue sauce you do that like any
grocery store like a Ralph's perhaps
it's got a stronger kick to it
but it's much sweeter than the first one
it's made like grocery store barbecue
sauce yeah cuz I'm kind of like a
simpleton I was like ooh this hasn't he
wants something so this one is a little
spicier I like my barbecue sauces to
have a little bit of kick I think this
is expensive you think that one's
expensive well cuz it makes you think
about what you just put in your mouth
[Music]
that looks like a joke almost thicker
than the last one I like the small
amount one good it has what I think to
be a smoky flavor or it could be the
macey dog I was gonna go a sponge ball
smoke here really yeah I gotta taste it
I can't it smells good yeah it smells
good doesn't smell sweet this I want to
put on chicken mmm tastes a little bit
like childhood there mm-hmm
what did your target taste like what did
they like this it's the closer to the
sweetness scale of the first one but it
also has that spice honestly I like the
cheap stuff me too I'm gonna go with
number two being the best for me just
was the first one I was like any kind of
you know like he said fast food barbecue
sauce you can just pick up for the free
I mean nowadays they're like charging 99
cents for one of them I mean I like the
the small packet one in the best this is
number two and then the one before was
my third ranking and there's a seat I
see like specks of stuff yeah see
something was chopped at one point here
yeah there's more debris floating freely
in the
ingredients areas that was the word
wanna say debris okay yeah I said the
brilliance yeah so I think the first one
was the cheapest based on the packaging
I think the second one was the most
expensive and I think the third one was
in the middle I agree
first when we tried is the cheapest it's
free free barbecue sauce second one we
tried I'm gonna say is the medium range
okay third what we tried is the most
expensive all right yeah it's the first
one yet freak the third one is like so
sweet
yeah anytime anything is really sweet it
makes me suspicious like what like
what's going on like were they are they
penny so much sugar in here yeah so
again I'll say that that's the middle
one the third one is the middle and the
second was expensive not for that one I
would not spend $20 for the third
barbecue so you have the bottles on you
see my final thought I have never in my
life seen anything like this but I'm
obsessed and I'm gonna use this what's
weird to eat up though yeah you do have
this been licked by someone I don't know
like this one it's so gross it was a
nice treat yeah kids don't stick foreign
objects in your mouth
[Music]